I want to go a different direction I
just want to ask you a question it's
just more kind of about human nature do
you think human beings are naturally
good or naturally bad as human nature to
Beulah rasa I really think we are blank
slate maybe I mean maybe there's some
inclination we're hardwired to be social
I know that
um or also at least to some extent
hardwired to be self-serving the best
Society merges those two the best
interest for you is the best interest
for everyone the social contract from
now until we die locks Rousseau's or
hubs Which social contract ah
I guess I would just say the ubiquitous
philosophical term more so than well
because they all they all wrote on those
terms right and they totally disagree
they all thought different things of
humans they all thought Hobbes was at a
very dark view we're so very positive
Locke was in more neutral so serious
socialists tend to think that human
beings are fundamentally positive but I
I reject that that's why I'm curious
because you don't see you see way too
cynical for them well the implicit
suggestion to that to me is that
socialists think their system would only
work if everyone was nice and I don't
believe that I think that the best
economic systems will work when everyone
is an absolute POS just a dirty horrible
human being and very obsidifies them
well but it should maybe humans are
amazing but the best system should
survive human grade I wanna I wanna ask
you a very simple and general question
uh-oh those are the worst ones dancing
is do you think some people are better
than other people
can I add a bit of nuance to that answer
answer however you want I think that
some people have been developed to be
more moral and of better character oh no
okay yeah I didn't I didn't mean moral
just better like like like they're
taller that's it oh um however but I I
think you know your interpretation of
the question is part of the answer by
any metric there will always be people
who are better than others always
perhaps by some combination of
environment and genetics I just hope
that we can all Ride Along by each other
I agree I think uh you know I mentioned
this before the show if you were to ask
anybody on the left or the right you
know what what did you want it would be
like for everyone to prosper for for
people to be successful to pull people
out of poverty things like that I guess
the issue is disagree on how we get
there well I think we want I'm not sure
if we want the same thing
um I want more of a preservation and
conservation of what we already have do
you want socialism absolutely not oh no
we the slight ideological as well but
come on come on I mean but like we don't
need to play the word games why do you
want to preserve I think that we have
something beautiful unique and
exceptional and I take the more Hobson
view of human nature which is we're
brutish and nasty and awful and cruel
the fact we've been able to build
something decent and civil is pretty
remarkable but are you saying that we
have a good system a great system and it
and people uh Thrive from the system I
think people flourish and Thrive I think
that a rights-based system is naturally
the best way to govern do you want
people to be stripped of their rights
imprisoned brutalized impoverished of
course not no and I mean the sacrificing
of Rights is something that usually has
to be earned negatively like murdering
somebody so this is what I mean because
I think I can ask you the same question
you know do you want people to be
brutalized impoverished imprisoned
of course not taking the rights away but
I would never want to grow complacent
you're both familiar with the marxian
theory of dialectic materialism you mean
oh no he had uh he had the dialectic and
we we built on it you know we uh no I
really want to get into the marks thing
because I'm super fascinated by it no I
well I just want to say you know the
theory I mean put simply I guess is that
um Human Society the human project it
evolves as a product of antagonism
grinding antagonism between people in
the marketing view different it's very
hug alien Yeah well yeah no I mean he
was a student of Hegel I know he was
part of this youth the young hegelian
yeah won the argument well no I'm not
well you're not I'm just saying like he
would get mad at you if you said he was
hegelian influence but I don't think I
would Hagel was a smart guy I just can't
read his work because the phenomenology
of spirit is impossible to read thank
you all right I was worried you're gonna
make fun of me I just want to say no
it's really hard he made the very simple
complex yeah he was we agree on
something I just want to say sorry sorry
I just want to is it the project of
humans moving forward I think that
antagonism fuels it but in the best way
not antagonism like War but antagonism
in the sense that we we look at our
ideas our values and we challenge them
so I just want to say something we
disagree on I don't think human
Humanity's a project
do you think we're headed towards
something better than what we have today
probably not I think that we're actually
we're probably engaging in the second
law of Thermodynamics currently that
we're untangling we're going to chaos
not order see this to me this is the
thing and I'm not trying to patronize
conservatives have been shown to be more
fearful on average and I think if they
thought that way it would be very
warranted but some fears are legitimate
certainly Winston Churchill's fear is
about the evil Germans were legitimate
no no I'm not no fear is not always
illegitimate and there are elements of
this I think though that if Society is
to collapse it would probably be from
climate change more so than like the oh
come on you don't believe that no for
sure you you can we'll see it assuming
yukova doesn't get you will live to see
some pretty severely we see it right now
you know my problem is oh you're like I
I see all the news I see all the
arguments about climate change and I'm
like I understand them and then you get
Obama buying beachfront property you get
the celebrities funding airplanes and
I'm like how am I supposed to trust
people gotta get Bernie guy rode the
train to work he didn't have to do that
Bernie's The Man true revolutionary so
just I'm sorry because I kept getting
sidetracked the idea of the human
project is super interesting to me
because that's a collision point we're
going to have so yeah well
I'd like to think I mean people have
always said this is the best it gets you
know the Postmaster General back end was
it the Postmaster General was it the
patent the patent office 1900 all the
patents have been made yeah yeah and I'm
not saying it's the best it's been it
I'm not saying Improvement is not maybe
we can make little improvements but when
I I try to put myself in the shoes of
men past you know I don't know somebody
in feudal China and to them what I live
in today would have been
incomprehensible to them in every
imaginable sense every conceivable way
but their arguments for the permanence
of society then would have been better
than mine today because they would have
lived in a stable feudal society for
Millennia and today I now am here using
technology that would have been alien to
humans 20 years ago I think about like
um
the cultural revolution the cultural
revolution I think about the Revolution
in Russia and you mentioned that
conservatives tend to be more fearful
and I think there's history that shows
us things can go bad you can have
something that's good not great could
probably be better
and then end up with an unchecked
movement that results in millions dead
for sure 20 to 40 million I think in the
cultural we had Lily Tong Williams on
the other hand she's telling us these
stories are scary always hindsight right
because people thought this about every
major event in Social progress in
America's history as well the breakup
the Confederacy the Civil War the fight
to abolish slavery sure you know
suffrage for women yes the Civil Rights
Act yes gay marriage yes every time we
make a step forward I don't you're
probably not to gay marriage right
because in pro-traditional marriage okay
sure right anti-game Rich
um pro-tradition yeah gotcha
um one man one woman every time we take
a step forward well we agreed on the
three parent household before I
disagreed on the polyama reaction 50
more efficient than the previous method
and that's not actually in a study and
ten times more chaotic are you actually
way more perverse I'm not actually
citing anything it's possibly not a
linear growth pattern with parents in
the house it's actually exponential it
just goes up forever Einstein had 12
parents yes but the time you hit 12
parents should the children just a God
by the way
very Uber Mensch but continue yeah sorry
um it always feels like everyone argues
like this is the best it gets and any
future steps would be treacherous but
then we always make that next step I
don't know if America is going to be
around forever we're a young country and
countries far older than ours have
fallen in the lifetime of America so I
can't look at what we have today or the
people that I live with or the values
that I believe in and assign to them a
feeling of permanence but I can say this
I fear stagnation and every country that
has ever set itself upon stagnation has
always died every time every country
always seeks to better itself and maybe
that road to betterment leads to ruin
but the path of stagnation is always
ruinous I I agree our culture has
stagnated severely one thing I always
bring up is like Christmas music written
in the 50s we still play it non-stop
over and over again movies have become
repetitive redundant reboots it's it's
it's devolved from where we had these
interesting pieces of Art to just
regurgitated crap over and over again
can I just take some exception with your
argument first of all there is this kind
of revisionist belief that somehow
conservatives in the traditional sense
were against some of those social
movements which is just not true now I'm
not saying you'd be a Confederate and
I'm not even getting to the party
switching thing but there is a direct
lineage between hyper focusing on racial
politics in the 1860s and the 1920s and
some of the people on the American left
that are just completely obsessed with
American you know racial politics it's
equality versus hierarchy right but what
do you what do you mean by that well
back then the slave owners wouldn't have
been like I'm really obsessed with race
or equality you know now I mean it's
obsession with race can be pernicious in
many ways but I think there's a pretty
big difference between being obsessed
with the idea of racial equality and
being obsessed I think it's equally as
pernicious just they don't have the
power to implement it but we we kind of
already did that do you think I do that
like you no I don't think you would I
mean I don't know you well enough you
seem rather decent I try my best but but
like like I wouldn't give power to
Nicole Hannah Jones I don't know how
that is who's she founded the 1619
project oh I I just read the thing I
don't know we have a constitution to
prevent us against people like that what
I'm saying though is that for example
I'm not against social change I mean I'd
love to abolish abortion for example I'd
love to put fathers back in the home no
doubt so conservatives are not
necessarily always saying no we don't
want to improve we want to stagnate we
want the correct form of social change
so let me ask this then let's get to the
core of it then what values are you
looking to maximize not just a great
question not just like morality because
that could be the same thing or
different things to anyone but if you
were like if you were to look at a
society and were asked to assess its
worth what metrics would you look
towards It's ability to defend those
that can't defend themselves okay
charity generosity integrity
Faith to your creator the ability to
pass down good and moral values to the
next generation one that believes in
work and one that believes in the cause
of the nation above the self
all right I've got a nice I think that's
a fairly collectivist point that last
one though wouldn't it be well the
nation above itself you could call it
collectivist but I wouldn't say the
state I'd say the idea of the nation
right so there's two different things
and those are conflated sometimes by
libertarian socialist types which is a
walking contradiction I'd love to ask
you about that sure but just like it's
kind of just being like a Christian
atheist I might answer it when you're
done by the way yeah I think my
follow-up definitely but the the state
is a creation of the people the people
are the country that's why our
constitution the Preamble says we the
people not we the federal government
right so the people are the nation and
so that's why I differentiate between
the two do you have a loyalty do you
have a belief that you want to create
something bigger than yourselves I think
that's a moral good to me and I I mean
this with uh without meaning to
hyperbolize but to me that's always
strong rather fascist the myth of the
Common Man the people the Volk you know
the idea that there is a state and
Germany was a state of course but Hitler
didn't really appeal to the state it was
the concept of the Fatherland that he
really hit on and the people were a
beating heart of the Fatherland they
were an instrumental organ and to me the
problem with this is that when you get
down to it this thought process this
mentality it drives men to do terrible
terrible things because interpersonally
all of the chemical effects of empathy
kick in I look at you I see you but you
start bringing in Concepts like the
nation the Fatherland and it becomes
very easy to convince people to compel
themselves towards courses that they
would otherwise not so
expected you to use a 1930s reference
earlier so congratulations
you did do the correct I didn't mean to
hyperbolize but there's other nations
today that have those values that we
would never call fascists like Japan uh
well Japan has very strict immigration
well I think Korea is actually a better
example to be honest I really don't like
either of those countries for the
reasons that I don't like Korea I think
they're both deeply conservative
countries I agree with you right they're
wonderful and I think they do so in part
because they're um there's a degree of
anti-individualism in the subservience
they all expect of the common good now
it's funny I feel like our roles are
being reversed a little bit here isn't
that interesting the common good isn't
something I appeal to for me the value I
want to maximize I just appeal to The
Good the good sure which is two
different things
um is freedom that's what I care about
most and that's what libertarian
socialism is about there are many types
of freedoms positive and negative if I
might indulge very briefly like is a man
thrown to a a lawless desert with out
food water or clothing free really
asking so probably no
I agree he's free to die but that's an
extreme example you're not applicable in
modern wealthy Americans no or any
Western Nation but it's a philosophical
base it's also a resilient argument
man's Born Free and he you know spends
the rest of his life In Chains It's just
anti-commercial in nature well no but
it's it's a base philosophical argument
because it's true they're Lawless
there's nothing preventing him from
doing anything in that environment but
he has no ability to act on it do you
know what he does have Consciousness
well sure so that's a natural rights
doctrine that I will defend well I I
mean I like Consciousness too the only
point that I'm getting at is when it
comes to people's freedom and the
ability for people to protect their
freedom this is what I care about it's
what Marx cared about if you actually
read what he wrote and I I have I've
read Das Capital I've read the
manifestation guess what he was right
about some things then you know but not
everything he didn't talk really wrong
about equality he didn't write on
equality he wrote on freedom because he
believed that Society was a very complex
interlocking network of systems that in
some ways liberated men and in other
ways enslaved but do you know what he
got wrong long he got wrong that
sometimes people can be free for other
devices that they are not able to
regulate they can be free not from
alcoholism drug addiction some sort of
any other sort of perverse addiction the
idea of freedom is a very libertarian
but I agree with that though no I know
you do the greatest I say that okay go
ahead I'm sorry just the greatest
Society is one or a man is born and
there are as few things as possible
preventing him from doing whatever he
wants for the rest of his life totally
disagreeing so long as of course he
doesn't deprive others of the ability to
do the same so I think that's a
miserable Society Freedom no that's not
Freedom that's licentiousness or
degeneracy that's chaos what does
degeneracy
I like men how about pedophilia okay
well you said whatever he wants is that
is the freedom as long as they don't
infringe in the rights of others I'm
sure you could believe I would believe
well so then so there are limits on
freedoms what you're saying it's not
this wild west campaign and so where do
you get those limits from well obviously
you would probably have to have a pretty
complex interlocking legal system to
determine what we agree upon is like a
reasonable limits we can place on
people's behavior we have that now to an
extent no I know so like pedophilia bad
that would be a bad thing okay
kidnapping that would be a bad thing
rape that would be a bad thing why do
you think those things are bad uh I
think they're bad because you're
stripping other people of the ability to
do that which they will with all those
examples you're inflicting harm on a
person how about dealing drugs uh I
think that dealing drugs is a person's
Freedom as is taking over here what
about dealing drugs to kids uh dealing
drugs to kids uh I think I would
disagree with that probably because I
think there's something exceptional
about addictive substances and children
that being said I think a lot of stuff
would apply to Children specifically
contract law kids can't sign contracts
I'm getting at eventually you do agree
that a conservative framework is
necessary but I don't think that's a
conservative framework because there are
other things I care about that you would
always disagree with like Collective
ownership of the means production which
I think private property and freedom are
linked together which would give workers
the most Freedom possible thanks for
checking out this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time